[Musik]
>> SALLY: Ach.
>> MURAT: So.
Bin ich drin?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja? Läuft?
>> SALLY: Ja, ja. Es geht los.
>> MURAT: Ja? Beim ersten Mal schon? Cool.
>> SALLY: Beim ersten Mal schon.
>> MURAT: Jo.
>> SALLY: Ja, vielleicht heute eine kleine Änderung.
Also hallo, herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ihr dürft heute jetzt mal live miterleben,
wie bei uns ein Podcast entsteht.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Unser Podcast ist jetzt, glaube ich, die 14. Folge.
>> MURAT: Ja. Und ich frage mich,
wo ich die letzten 13 Folgen war.
Ich habe alles vergessen.
>> SALLY: Und ich denke mir so, seit 14 Folgen
oder seit 13 Folgen gibt es schon unseren Podcast
jede Woche aufs Neue immer donnerstagabends
und
– beziehungsweise den ganzen Donnerstag.
Und ja, den Podcast habe ich bisher
immer mit Murat gemacht.
Aber du hast ja auch schon mal einen Podcast
mit dem Bahti gemacht, also mit Teammitgliedern.
>> MURAT: Genau, einen Podcast habe mich
mit Bahti gemacht.
>> SALLY: Genau.
>> MURAT: Das mit
– ich habe eigentlich einen Podcast mit dem Güni gemacht,
aber der wurde wieder zensiert.
>> SALLY: Ja. Den müsst ihr vielleicht noch mal neu machen.
>> MURAT: Ja, der war dann FSK 18.
>> SALLY: Ja. Weil eigentlich war diese Woche
ein Podcast mit Güni geplant,
aber dann haben wir gesagt: "Nee, komm."
Und damit ihr mal sehen könnt,
wie es bei uns so hinter den Kulissen aussieht.
Wir sitzen hier bei uns im Büro, Gästezimmer
/ der Raum, der frei war im Erdgeschoss
für alles, was sich ansammelt im Haus.
>> MURAT: Die Kinder sind oben.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Die haben wir schon schlafen gebracht.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und ja, jetzt dürft ihr einfach mal
ein bisschen mithören und mitschauen.
>> MURAT: Und...
Ja, genau.
>> SALLY: Das war es, nicht?
>> MURAT: Das war es schon.
>> SALLY: Dann starten wir einfach direkt, oder?
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: Kurz und schmerzlos.
>> MURAT: Podcast – für die Leute,
die noch nie was von Podcast gehört haben:
Es gibt wirklich was.
Das ist nichts Perverses,
hat nichts mit perversen Sachen mit Tieren zu tun.
Es ist einfach nur eine audiovisuelle
– kann das sein?
>> SALLY: Nein, Audioaufnahme.
Visuell ist ja sehen, Audio ist hören.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Und deswegen Audioaufnahme.
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: Das heißt, so einen Podcast könnt ihr hören,
wenn ihr gerade putzt, wenn ihr Auto fahrt,
wenn ihr joggen seid.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Im Prinzip immer dann, wenn ihr gerade
etwas abschalten wollt oder auch nur auf dem Sofa liegt
und sagt: "Oh, jetzt ziehe ich mir Murat und Sally rein,
weil es lustig ist, unterhaltsam ist, informativ ist."
Das heißt, so ein Podcast ist eigentlich immer da
für die Freizeit, für die gute Laune.
Und ich glaube, unser Podcast ist auch
so ein Gute-Laune-Podcast.
>> MURAT: Wieso? Wir haben auch schlechte Themen
schon gehabt.
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja, von deiner Familie
haben wir schon lang nichts mehr geredet.
>> MURAT: Ah, hahaha, aha.
So.
Es könnte auch...
>> SALLY: Oh, war der schlagfertig!
>> MURAT: Hm.
Hm.
>> SALLY: Das habe ich von ihm gelernt übrigens.
>> MURAT: So. Auf jeden Fall...
>> SALLY: So was hätte ich früher nie, never ever gesagt.
>> MURAT: Jetzt echt ehrlich gesagt, ja, stimmt wirklich.
Du bist so richtig...
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Egal.
>> SALLY: Weil du mich so gemacht hast.
>> MURAT: Okay.
Auf jeden Fall, für uns ist das natürlich auch
so ein gewisse Therapie, muss man ganz ehrlich sagen.
>> SALLY: Ja, eigentlich schon.
Also eigentlich nutzen wir euch aus,
um für uns eine Gesprächs- und Ehetherapie zu machen.
>> MURAT: Genau. Weil wir haben so viel zu tun eigentlich
tagsüber, dass wir eigentlich kaum miteinander reden.
>> SALLY: Und wir haben einfach gemerkt...
>> SALLY: Und das ist auch das Geheimnis,
dass wir schon lange so zusammen sind.
>> SALLY: Ja, seit 13 Jahren.
Und falls ihr noch keinen Podcast gehört habt,
wirklich, fangt bei Folge 1 an,
hört es euch an.
Wir erzählen euch, wie wir uns kennengelernt haben,
die Hochzeit,
mit den Kindern,
wie Sallys Welt entstanden ist.
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: Ja, eigentlich war es wirklich so.
Wir haben die ersten 13 Jahre unseres Ehelebens
nie so richtig anscheinend miteinander geredet.
Aber jetzt lernen wir uns
noch mal auf einem anderen Level kennen.
>> MURAT: Schön dich kennenzulernen,
>> SALLY: Schön dich auch kennenzulernen.
>> MURAT: Sally. Ja.
>> SALLY: Wollen wir uns nächste Woche wieder daten?
>> MURAT: Nein, kommt drauf an.
>> SALLY: Okay. Aber jetzt komm.
Komm, jetzt legen wir los, oder?
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Weil,
ja, das erfahrt ihr ja alles schon in den anderen Podcastfolgen.
>> MURAT: Genau. Alltags-, tägliche Dinge.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Also hallo, herzlich willkommen!
>> MURAT: Hier ist die Sally.
>> SALLY: Wir müssen ja
– also wir müssen ja ein bisschen jetzt mitdenken.
Denn wir machen jetzt für euch ein Video,
aber wir müssen ja unseren Podcast so gestalten,
dass es keiner merkt.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> MURAT: Also fangen wir an?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Okay, los.
>> SALLY: Gut.
>> MURAT: Bin ich drin?
>> SALLY: Ja, du bist drin.
>> MURAT: Jawoll.
So.
Herzlich willkommen bei Sallys Podcast
>> SALLY: mit Murat
>> MURAT: mit Sally
in alter Frische.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Heute wieder aus dem Büro.
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: Die Kids sind im Bett.
>> SALLY: Und deswegen haben wir uns gedacht,
komm, alles, was uns wieder aktuell bewegt,
teilen wir mit euch.
>> MURAT: Genau.
So. Wo fangen wir an?
>> SALLY: Ja, ich glaube, wir fangen beim Unfall an.
Denn viele haben schon gefragt.
>> MURAT: Nee. Müssen wir beim Unfall anfangen?
>> SALLY: Ja, ich weiß auch nicht.
>> MURAT: Ihr habt es wahrscheinlich schon im Bild gesehen.
Ich habe...
>> SALLY: Es tut mir zutiefst leid!
Ich muss es euch sagen, es tut mir wirklich zutiefst leid.
Es war
folgende Situation.
>> MURAT: Darf ich das
– darf ich anfangen? Dann darfst du weitermachen, okay?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Also Folgendes:
Ich habe einfach zu lange Haare gehabt.
Und ich bin so ein Typ...
>> SALLY: Kannst du sagen "am Kopf"?
>> MURAT: Am Kopf, ja.
Nee, am Rücken. Na, wo denn sonst?
>> SALLY: Es ist ein Podcast und da hört man oft nicht,
worum es geht, weil man macht ja auch Gestik, Mimik.
Und sage bitte einfach "am Kopf".
>> MURAT: Ja, okay. Alles klar.
Weißt du, wie du bist? Du bist wie mein Lehrer.
Wenn ich sage, "17", sagt er: "17 was?"
Okay.
>> SALLY: Hühner.
>> MURAT: Ja, genau, zum Beispiel.
Euro.
So. Auf jeden Fall war es so.
Ich mag es...
Ich habe keine Zeit, zum Friseur zu gehen.
Ich bin kein eitler Mensch
und habe zu meiner Frau gesagt:
"Komm, Schatz, oben ist einfach der Rasierapparat.
Tu mir einen Gefallen.
Mach mir die Haare einfach auf 5 mm,
zack, durch und fertig.
Und dann ziehe ich eine Mütze an und was weiß ich
und das war es.
Okay?"
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: So.
Also habe ich meine Frau hochgerufen.
Und ich habe so ein cooles Gerät.
Das war echt teuer.
Also...
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> MURAT: Ja, das hat 30 € gekostet.
>> SALLY: Ah, okay.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> MURAT: Ja. So.
>> SALLY: Gut, für so einen elektrischen Rasierer. Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Es hat ja nicht jeder so einen Dyson-Föhn
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: oder was das Ding ist.
>> SALLY: War das jetzt eine Produktplatzierung?
>> MURAT: Ja. Nein, sage ich nur.
>> SALLY: Ja. Aber man muss dazu sagen...
>> MURAT: Die Leute
– Insider wissen, was ich damit sagen möchte.
Aber ist auch egal. 30 €.
>> SALLY: Und ich hatte noch nie
so einen elektrischen Rasierer in der Hand.
>> MURAT: So.
Und dann hat meine Frau mir einfach die Haare
– natürlich das Gerät auf 5 mm eingestellt
oder 4 mm. Ich weiß nicht mehr.
>> SALLY: 7.
>> MURAT: Sieben? O mein Gott!
>> SALLY: 7 waren es.
>> MURAT: Okay. 7 mm eingestellt
und sie ist mir halt komplett
über den Kopf gefahren die ganze Zeit.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ab und zu habe ich mal anhalten müssen,
weil da habe ich die Haare rausbürsten müssen
aus diesem Vorsatz
und habe es dann kurz mal wieder ölen müssen
mit allem Drum und Dran.
Mein Gott, es ist ein 30-€-Rasierer. Was sollen wir erwarten?
Und dann auf jeden Fall – dann habe ich dann...
>> SALLY: Dann musste ich
– weil deine Haare hinten so dicht sind,
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: musste ich sogar zur Schere greifen,
weil der Rasierer das nicht geschafft hat.
Also es war wirklich
– der hat so dichte Haare am Hinterkopf,
der Rasierer hat es nicht geschafft.
Also habe ich zur Schere gegriffen
und wie meine Friseurfreundin Lisa
so mit der Schere, mit dem Kamm
so richtig professionell, muss man sagen,
die Haare geschnitten.
>> MURAT: Hm. Es war wahnsinnig professionell.
Ich kann mich noch...
>> SALLY: Aber es war teilweise länger, teilweise...
>> MURAT: Übrigens, da gibt es ein Video.
Wir haben das aufgenommen. Aber egal.
>> SALLY: Teilweise länger, teilweise...
Ich habe es
– okay, wir haben es aufgenommen,
weil ich dachte so: "Komm, wir machen
einen coolen Zeitraffer, was wir so abends machen."
>> MURAT: Hm,
>> SALLY: Aber dann ist leider
>> MURAT: die Haare rasieren.
>> SALLY: ein Fail geworden.
>> MURAT: Ja. Und dann auf jeden Fall...
>> SALLY: Ein leichter Fail.
>> MURAT: Und dann hat der Rasierapparat
nicht mehr funktioniert.
Dann habe ich den auseinandergebaut.
Und ihr wisst, da gibt es ja solche Vorsätze,
7 mm, 3 mm, 5 mm.
Und da war ja jetzt der 7-mm-Aufsatz drauf.
Dann habe ich den runtergemacht
und habe dann die...
>> SALLY: Dann hast du ihn erst mal dreimal fallen lassen.
>> MURAT: Ja. Und dann habe ich
– dann die Dinger habe ich ein bisschen eingeölt,
habe ihn sauber gemacht.
Und dann habe ich vergessen,
den Aufsatz wieder draufzumachen.
>> SALLY: Murat?
>> MURAT: Und meine Frau, die greift halt hin...
Ja?
>> SALLY: Das war jetzt deine Wahrheit.
Meine Wahrheit
– und das ist auch die Wahrheit, die man im Video sieht,
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: denn wir haben es auf Kamera –
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: war: Du hast den nicht auseinandergebaut
und nicht geölt,
du hast ihn fallen lassen
und währenddessen hast du Küchle Chips da gegessen.
Was war es? Esspapier.
>> MURAT: Esspapier. Ja, stimmt.
>> SALLY: Esspapier hast du gegessen.
Dann hast du den auf den Boden gefallenen Rasierer
wieder aufgehoben, hast ihn zusammengebaut
und mir hingelegt.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: So.
>> MURAT: Und jetzt?
>> SALLY: Und ich habe zum Rasierer gegriffen,
weil du mir ihn ja hingelegt hast,
weil er doch fertig von dir montiert war.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und ich fahre ihm praktisch
– weil ich wollte ja von unten ansetzen.
Und ich fahre ihm praktisch von unten nach oben
mit dem Rasierer.
>> MURAT: Hey, das ist echt...
Weißt du, dass, dass du das lustig findest,
mich voll aggressiv macht?
Ehrlich.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Und ich habe ihm halt voll die Bahn reinrasiert
und habe die halt erst...
>> MURAT: Ja, weißt du?
>> SALLY: Ich habe sie halt erst gesehen,
als ich praktisch oben war.
Weil man sieht ja nicht, wenn die Hand drüber ist.
O mein Gott!
>> MURAT: Ja, wie unfähig kann man sein?!
Und so sieht es jetzt aus.
So.
Sieht man das?
>> SALLY: Das Schlimme ist...
Das Schlimme ist ja, dass ich
– eigentlich sah es ja vorher echt gut aus.
Aber ich wollte ja dieses kleine Loch korrigieren,
was ich mit der Schere gemacht habe.
Und ich habe gesagt: "O mein Gott!
Ich habe ein Loch reingemacht! Das tut mir leid."
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und ich wollt das Loch korrigieren und jetzt...
Mein Gott! Ich bin halt keine Friseurin.
>> MURAT: Ja, das ist mir...
>> SALLY: Und ich habe noch nie
so einen Rasierer zusammengebaut.
Es war deine Schuld.
>> MURAT: Ja. Aber egal. Auf jeden Fall, das war es.
>> SALLY: Du bist doch trotzdem ein hübscher Mann.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und im Shop letzte Woche in Mannheim...
>> MURAT: Genau. Da hat mich eine Frau gefragt,
>> SALLY: Eine?
>> MURAT: ob ich krank wäre,
ob ich krank wäre, ob es mir gut geht.
>> SALLY: Anscheinend...
>> MURAT: Da habe ich gesagt: "Warum?"
Da sagt sie, ja, weil mir hinten die Haare rausfallen.
Dann sage ich: "Hä?"
Und dann dachte ich mir: "O Gott, nein!"
Und das sieht man halt voll und das sieht halt komisch aus.
>> SALLY: Das war ein bisschen peinlich.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay, das ist
>> MURAT: Okay, Thema beendet.
Dann
>> SALLY: nicht so schlimm alles.
>> MURAT: war eine coole Geschichte.
Und zwar vor vier Tagen
bekommen wir eine coole Anfrage.
>> SALLY: Darf ich die erzählen?
O mein
– o Gott! Darf ich sie vorlesen?
>> MURAT: Und diese Anfrage,
die möchte ich euch erzählen.
So.
Und zwar hatten wir eine Anfrage
von einer
– erzähl es du bitte kurz, Sally.
>> SALLY: Und zwar hatten wir eine Anfrage.
Es geht um den Podcast.
Und in der Anfrage ging es eben darum,
dass die Person gesagt hat:
"Euer Podcast ist ja der Hammer,
gerade für Pärchen,
>> MURAT: Ja, genau.
>> SALLY: für Liebesbeziehungen,
für Mamis und Papis."
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und sie haben gefragt,
ob wir nicht mal bei deren
– auf deren Plattform einen Podcast machen wollen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Darf ich den Namen sagen?
>> MURAT: Ja. Aber es war doch nett.
Ich finde das lustig...
>> SALLY: Das war voll nett gesagt.
>> MURAT: Ja, ja.
>> SALLY: Auf femtasy.
Und dann habe ich mir schon gedacht: "Oh!"
>> MURAT: Das Ding heißt femtasy.
>> SALLY: Das klingt schon so.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und das ist so eine Erotik-Podcast-Plattform.
Ich meine, ganz ehrlich, zwischen uns läuft es ja auch gut.
>> MURAT: Ja. Aber das...
Aber ich glaube, die fanden meine Stimme so sexy.
>> SALLY: Ja, ich habe dann mir den Spaß gemacht
und habe mal bei femtasy reingehört.
Das ist jetzt wirklich keine bezahlte Produktplatzierung.
>> MURAT: Also das ist keine Produktplatzierung.
>> SALLY: Nicht, dass ihr jetzt denkt...
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: Ich habe die Anfrage noch nicht beantwortet.
Ich habe sie nur gelesen.
Und dann habe ich mir gedacht,
okay, ich gucke jetzt mal, was es da so gibt.
Aber, Murat, du musst dir dann einen Kosenamen ausdenken.
>> MURAT: Ich weiß es nicht und zwar...
>> SALLY: Weil das Ding ist, ich habe dann
– du kannst dir so einen Sprecher aussuchen.
Und dann ist da zum Beispiel einer,
der sagt dann so: "Hi, ich bin Stefan.
Und ich erkläre dir" so und so.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und dann, wenn du halt sagst
– sag mal du.
>> MURAT: Kann es sein, das was mit dir nicht stimmt?
Weil ich habe die Zeit gar nicht, so was anzuhören
nur mal so nebenher.
Ich sage dann:
>> SALLY: Eine Freundin war da und dann haben wir es halt...
>> MURAT: "Hallo. Ich bin dein neuer Gärtner.
Mein Name ist Murat."
>> SALLY: Das ist, glaube ich, das Problem, dass
>> MURAT: Warum?
>> SALLY: Wenn du sagst "Murat", dann
>> MURAT: Was ist dann?
>> SALLY: assoziieren die Menschen vielleicht
nicht ganz so was Attraktives damit und denken vielleicht so...
>> MURAT: Wieso? Was heißt denn das? Was willst du?
Also muss ich "José" sagen, oder was?
>> SALLY: Vielleicht.
>> MURAT: Hallo, mein Name ist José.
>> SALLY: Ja! Ja!
>> MURAT: Ich bin aus Barcelona.
>> SALLY: Genau. So ein bisschen Lispeln finde ich...
>> MURAT: Ja, so ein bisschen.
>> SALLY: Das finden die Frauen auch immer attraktiv.
>> MURAT: Oder einen gewissen Akzent.
>> SALLY: Ich meine ja, das können wir uns ja noch überlegen.
Ich meine, vielleicht können ja die Zuschauer
mit bestimmen, ob wir das...
>> MURAT: Nee.
Mit Sicherheit bestimmen die Zuschauer nicht,
>> SALLY: Ach schade!
>> MURAT: was ich abends mache.
Mit Sicherheit nicht. So weit sind wir noch nicht, Fräulein.
>> SALLY: Vielleicht können sie ja eine Geschichte spinnen.
>> MURAT: Nein, ich will auch keine Geschichte.
>> SALLY: Nee. Aber ich würde sagen,
für euch ist hier erst mal Schluss.
Denn wir erzählen jetzt gerade noch
eine Dreiviertelstunde ungefähr,
was uns heute noch so bewegt hat,
was uns diese Woche bewegt.
Und falls ihr den kompletten Podcast hören wollt,
dann schaut doch einfach mal bei uns vorbei.
Der Podcast an sich ist wirklich kostenlos.
Er ist sehr unterhaltsam.
Und dann lasst ihr uns gerne euer Feedback da.
Und ja, wenn es euch gefällt, dann sehen wir uns
oder hören uns, besser gesagt, jeden Donnerstag.
>> MURAT: Ja. Und mit meiner Stimme.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und wir machen immer so ein...
>> MURAT: Ich finde auch, meine Stimme hört sich voll gut an.
>> SALLY: Ja, ja, finde ich auch.
>> MURAT: Ehrlich. Also, wenn ich jetzt
>> SALLY: Ich habe mich damals in deine Stimme verliebt.
>> MURAT: Also, wenn ich du wäre, wäre ich gern ich,
also ich.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> MURAT: Macht's gut!
>> SALLY: Ja. Aber ich finde, wie gesagt...
Und wir machen am Ende immer so einen Code,
also so ein Codewort, so einen Codesatz,
weil wir dann
– das ist halt immer witzig.
Weil wir machen ein Posting
und jeder, der den Podcast gehört hat,
>> MURAT: Der weiß genau, um was es geht.
>> SALLY: der schreibt dann so einen richtig weirden Satz,
so richtig durchgeknallt.
Und dann wissen wir ganz genau,
aha, die hat den Podcast gehört.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Deswegen, schaut gern vorbei und...
>> MURAT: Und das Krasse ist,
es ist wirklich unglaublich selten, dass
– also unsere Podcasts werden bis zu 92% angehört.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Und das ist normalerweise
– das ist ein ganz krasser Wert.
Weil normalerweise ist man
– ab 62% sind die meisten schon draußen.
>> SALLY: Ja, das stimmt.
>> MURAT: Das heißt, wir bauen immer eine Steigerung ein
>> SALLY: Wir haben eine Spannung.
>> MURAT: und dann denkst du, es passiert was irgendwie.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Und dann kommt wieder diese Melodie
und dann geht es nächste Woche weiter.
>> SALLY: Meinst du, es kommt irgendwann so
– ich meine, wir haben ja keine Aufschriebe oder so.
Aber meinst du, es kommt mal so ein Punkt,
wo wir sagen: "Hä, was erzählen wir heute?"?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich weiß es nicht.
>> MURAT: Gerade eben fällt mir nichts mehr ein.
>> SALLY: Echt? Aber ich habe Fragen gesammelt.
>> MURAT: Hast du Fragen gesammelt an mich?
>> SALLY: Klar. Ich bin vorbereitet.
>> MURAT: Okay. Schieß los.
>> SALLY: Also wir sehen uns
nicht mehr mit dem Thema Podcast,
sondern wir hören uns.
Also schaltet gerne ein und lasst uns euer Feedback da.
Bis bald! Tschüss!
>> MURAT: Tschüss!
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Murat und ich, wir nehmen euch
ja wirklich bei allem mit.
Wir zeigen euch, was uns bewegt, was uns begleitet.
Und wir gehen jetzt tatsächlich
unter die Landwirte, also wir werden Landwirte.
[Musik]
>> MURAT: Das ist wirklich etwas Revolutionäres,
was die Landwirtschaft revolutionären kann in Deutschland
und auf der ganzen Welt.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Also so soll das Ganze
ja in Zukunft dann aussehen.
Gezeichnet ist es schon und geplant.
Und dann kann es in wenigen Wochen, Monaten losgehen,
damit es überall auf der Welt regionale Lebensmittel gibt.
[Musik]